mais ta première femme tu l'a rencontrée
l'été ambulancière fois j'étais soldat
ouais mais c'était dans la poche de
royan 140 non non la police et après
c'est en 44 la poche de royan c'est à un
endroit ou pour les allemands étaient
restés alors que tout le reste de la
france était et est libéré et est resté
marié combien de temps avec elle 20 ans
s'est terminé comme en mal
parce que ça tue le raconte jamais
justement mais je ne tiens pas à
raconter ça c'est quand même bien de se
garder des choses qu'on voit ici n'a pas
ici jetons qua non pour être supportés
par roger pierre est jalouse de roger
terre non non non non bah j'ai rencontré
une autre femme voilà d'accord tout bête
donc à flasher sur le bébé voilà un épi
tu as dis à ta femme je suis désolé bah
voilà bon d'accord pas comme ça on le
sait brigitte c'est simple je la leur ça
arrive des tas d'autres gens oui donc tu
as eu trois enfants et cette première
femme qui s'appelait comment madeleine
et et alors les enfants mia et xavier un
gars qui a quel grand temps qu'elle du
splendid
il ya prédéry qui fait aussi permis du
grand orchestre du splendid qui est
aussi qui vient d'écrire un opéra rock
sur les précieuses ridicules et puis une
fille s'appelle année il ya une petite
fille
fille d'annie s'appelle florine way
petite aiguille alors j'ai un enfant
avec sofia gaza ce qui s'appelle
alexandre qui lui aussi comédien bon tu
vois tu parles là ça y est la larme à
cuzin te demander tu vas tout nous
raconter alors par l'entreprise
agacinski su sauver alors tu vas
rencontrer commencé important dans un
film ouais un film tu étais pas très bon
d'ailleurs c'est quoi
parce qu'il était à lui comme à tout le
monde de faire des films qui permettait
de payer les impôts du bois bon alors
sur lui en était un et s'était tu tiens
à une époque où il y avait de ces films
où il y avait une sorte de brigade des
comics tu vois il ya francis blanche
darid paul poiret serrault nous et tout
à et et les producteurs avant goût pour
le cribiq à l'époque était pas vraiment
pas terrible faute parce qu'il faisait
maintenant un belge où la jeune première
ah oui voilà c'est arrivé dans le sprint
a flashé sur elle
voilà tu allé lui dire que quelqu'un est
beaucoup plus jeune que toi là combien
de moins que toi 20 ans ah oui donc allé
lui dire comment ça s'est passé
bah oui je lui ai dit enfin chez prost
s'est vu peut-être tu a conclu vite
après oui relativement vite
normalement lorsque fille qu'il a
rencontré en 65
ouais et il a épousé quand 83 pourquoi
j'ai vécu en concubinage ou un an
désormais à voir j'ai honte tu devrais
te vois tu laves épousé alors parce que
notre fils nous l'a demandé est simple à
gaza ce kit ouais on souhaitait de sa
gueule à l'école en tout cas il
il nous a demandé de le faire et on l'a
fait vous êtes marié c'était une nouba
du tonnerre ah oui c'était un régal hier
dans ta maison là ouais ouais
à un moment un copain nous avait jamais
chouih et on a retrouvé 250 ce programme
amal prend cette maison t'as mis trois
ans pour la trouver on secoue la retape
et ali tout en peignant maintenant
presque oui oui tous les stades ou trois
par cette maison barria comment ça se
passe avec les voisins eygalières ça se
passe bien
ouais pas de problème c'est très copain
avec eux à oui mais c'est que dès que
des paysans autour de chez moi il
convient aux belges je crois j'espère
mais tu peux jamais savoir parce que les
pronoms choses ont quand même de garder
leur identité ils aiment bien qu'on
vienne chez eux qu'on aime leur pays bas
ils ont palma les attaquantes à soi
c'est normal vous acceptez comme ça du
jour au lendemain si tu avais été un
membre de la direction de l'ol paie et
on voit que ça se serait passé aussi
bien pour toi à eygalières mais regarde
seulement prendre ton petit téléviseur
et regarde